2015 has been a year of unprecedented
visibility for the transgender community
but it's also been a year of
unprecedented violence nearly twice as
many trans people have been murdered in
2015 than in 2014
LGBTQ people are eight point three times
more likely to be victims of violence
among those transgender people are 1.6
times more likely and are seven times
more likely to experience violence from
police than their cisgendered
counterparts trans women account for 55%
of all victims of anti-transgender
violence 50% of those are women of color
the FBI began tracking hate crimes based
on gender identity in 2013 as the
transgender community becomes more
visible will things change
you